[Music]  warning this film contains an unlikable  female protagonist viewer discretion  advised  have you ever wanted to be noticed so  badly  you didn't even care what it was for  danny sanders might actually be the  worst person we've ever covered on the  show acting like she was the victim  turned a lot of people off to her i was  just gonna bleach the front bits but i'm  really not trying to get mistaken for  danny sanders  this is so [ __ ] up isn't it kevin  white women  my name is danny sanders and on april  10th a string of terrorist attacks  struck paris i almost died  just kidding  be careful what you [ __ ] wish for  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you